ans il vaut mieux parler en euros c'est
plus de 20 milliards d'euros de dépenses
de santé parce que c'était nécessaire et
que c'est quelque chose qui augmente
pour eux et c'est du 220 milliards un
toad en savon peut lui faire dire à peu
près ce qu'on veut donc voilà c'est la
bonne année pour le faire parce que
encore une fois c'est pas à notre à nos
dépens pensez plutôt à nos dépens je
suis désolé de retourner un bond du
ministre du ca fait préparer à répondre
à toutes les questions
madame v noirs jasmin oui alors moi je
suis scandalisé par ce qui vient de se
passer
ce qui est en train même de se passer je
suis scandalisé parce que nous sommes en
audition avec deux ministres dont le
ministre de la santé qui parle qui parle
alors qu'il sait très bien que nous
n'avons pas terminé
quand on regarde on la configuration et
le nombre de commissaires qui lie à
commission des affaires sociales je suis
vraiment jamais sûr je vraiment parce
que ce n'est pas normal qu ici au sénat
nous soyons dans une telle situation
surtout qu'il ya un an quand nous avons
préparé le plfss
et bien cette même majorité nous a
laissés en plan parce qu'il y avait la
pression de la rue alors est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il y ait aussi une pression
estime john huet je ne serai pas mais je
considère que c'est scandaleux et que
c'est du mépris à l'égard du sénat et
doit tous les commissaires qui sont là
ce n'est pas normal parce qu'il ya
encore des questions
le ministre a sans doute des impératifs
mais je trouve quand même qu'il aurait
dû au début de la séance le faire savoir
pour que nous puissions prendre des
dispositions donc jamais sujet je suis
vraiment désolé de le dire mais ce n'est
pas normal
nous sommes là nous existons et le
ministre il ne doit pas avoir quel
mépris à l'égard de l'ensemble du sénat
je rappelle qu'en début d'audition j'ai
dit que le ministre devrait partir un
moment on est dans des circonstances un
peu exceptionnel pour un ministre de la
santé
il a passé il a passé une heure et demie
avec nous mais au tout début de
l'audition il a bien dit que les
réponses seraient réparties et sur des
réponses à des questions s'étaient vus
avec le ministre du soft donc voilà je
lance à dame la présidente j'ai quand
j'avais quand même poser mes questions
parce que les au népal norman ce n'est
vraiment pas normal et monsieur il faut
sauf si vous pouvez aider à répondre
vous répondez mais j'aurais voulu quand
même qu'il ya des réponses